big milestone for the David Pakman show
achieved yesterday we reached 500,000
subscribers on our YouTube channel
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
and what I like to do whenever we reach
a big milestone on the YouTube channel
is look back at old analytics and I went
back and looked at the first month we
were on YouTube okay Pat was in
kindergarten at the time we had 721
views that month okay I didn't mean to
miss speak I'm not saying we had 721
viewers I'm not saying we had 721 views
per day the first month we were on
YouTube the entire month we ended up
with 721 views and four subscribers
three of which were probably accounts my
mom made okay those are the right
numbers in July of 2018
last month we added 16,000 subscribers
we had 16,000 new subscribers just last
July and more than 8.1 million views and
it happened
rolling over from 499 thousand 999
subscribers to the miraculous
majestic and towering number of 500,000
views I was sitting there watching it
Pat was sitting there watching it and it
was a moment to behold and this is huge
for us thanks to everyone of the 500
thousand now it's even more we're
already up to like five hundred thousand
one three hundred or something like that
so onward and upward to 1 million more
content more miniseries more long-form
pieces interviews everything but I do
want to say it's really not the
subscribers that matter it's the views
you could have a million subscribers and
no views and that's where our focus
continues to be people may not know this
but of our views only 30% come from
subscribers 70% of our entire channel
views are from non subscribers who
either see our video recommended when
watching something else or make a search
for something like Trump embarrasses
himself hugely in front of the Japanese
Prime Minister and maybe our video comes
up so subscribe
liber milestone very important but
onward and upward and continuing yeah
our channel is ranked 6000 in video
views which doesn't sound that
impressive until you compare it to like
the tens of millions of YouTube channels
out there and then it sounds pretty good
and then if you watch on TV or listen on
the radio or to the podcast then this
has nothing to do with any of your
experience with the show
so in that sense if you're not a YouTube
viewer I apologize for the interruption
and we're gonna take a quick break and
then get back to the meat of the
programming but if you are part of our
success on YouTube thank you I really do
appreciate it send your messages of
congratulations or of trolling and
predictions that this is almost the end
for the show which people do every day
on Twitter at D Pakman or to the show on
Twitter at David Pakman show